[Musik]
>> SALLY: Wir nennen den Kanal einfach um jetzt:
Sally-Freddie-Kanal.
>> FREDERIC: Wir müssen auch Shipping machen.
Dann müssen die beiden Namen zusammen.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> FREDERIC: Also
Sallie.
>> SALLY: Frally.
>> FREDERIC: Frally.
>> SALLY: Das Frally.
>> FREDERIC: Was geht? Wir sind es, Frally.
>> FREDERIC: Frally.
>> SALLY: Hallo! Herzlich willkommen zu Frallys Welt!
Das war es doch, Frally.
>> FREDERIC: Finde ich gut. Was ist mein Fachbereich?
>> SALLY: Oder Saddie?
>> FREDERIC: Was ist mein Fachbereich?
>> SALLY: Alles.
>> FREDERIC: Herzlich willkommen beim Fachbereich Alles!
Voraussichtlich eher im Bereich Produkttest:
"Ah, er schafft es nicht, das zu verwenden.
Das müssen wir anders machen."
>> SALLY: Ach, das schaffen wir schon.
Heute kochen wir
einen Eintopf:
Lancashire Hotpot.
Ein Rezept aus Nordengland,
was ich auf Pinterest entdeckt habe,
und dachte so: "Ah, das könnten wir doch mal kochen."
Und wir sind jetzt hier in der Küche.
Denn drüben in der Küche drehen wir aktuell
auch noch parallel, wir zwei,
unsere zwei anderen Ichs.
>> FREDERIC: Die Seelen.
>> SALLY: Die Seele,
>> FREDERIC: Die haben wir stehen gelassen.
>> SALLY: die kocht noch da drüben.
Jedenfalls, glaube ich, ist es echt ein cooles Gericht und
wird im Gusseisen zubereitet.
Das Ganze wird auch sehr schonend gegart
und eher bei niedrigen Temperaturen,
wir anscheinend superbutterzart und so weiter.
Und deswegen machen wir das einfach jetzt parallel.
>> FREDERIC: Hm.
>> SALLY: Weil da passt ja jetzt schon viel,
eine gute Portion rein.
Aber wir sind halt noch viel mehr Menschen da drüben.
>> FREDERIC: Hm.
>> SALLY: Deswegen machen wir jetzt gleich zwei Portionen.
Wir zeigen euch mal die Zutaten.
Also wir brauchen einen Esslöffel Butter,
einen Esslöffel Olivenöl,
400 Gramm Lammfleisch,
eine Zwiebel und eine Knoblauchzehe,
etwas Mehl,
Karotten,
– die sind bereits geschält –
500 Gramm Gemüsebrühe,
einen Esslöffel Soße,
– ich erkläre euch gleich was dazu –
Kartoffeln,
– die brauche ich nicht schälen,
weil sie einfach gewaschen sind –
Rosmarin,
Thymian,
Lorbeerblätter
und etwas Butter.
Das Zebra muss mit ins Bild.
Diese Soße, die hier ist,
das ist die Soße, die ich nie aussprechen kann.
>> FREDERIC: Wir hatten es gerade nachgeguckt.
>> SALLY: Wo- Wor-
>> FREDERIC: Wouster?
Woster?
>> SALLY: Worcher Sauce?
>> FREDERIC: Worster?
>> SALLY: Wouch-
>> COMPUTER: Worcester Sauce.
>> SALLY: Ach!
Es ist einfach...
Das schreibt man W-O-R-C-E-S-T-E-R
Sauce.
>> FREDERIC: Wouster?
>> SALLY: Worchs-
>> FREDERIC: Worcester.
>> SALLY: Worcester Sauce.
So viel zur Soße.
Und wir brauchen noch Salz und Pfeffer.
Wir starten jetzt direkt. Denn wir haben alle Hunger.
Also einfach mal Butter und Öl
rein.
Butter für den Geschmack
und Öl.
>> FREDERIC: Okay. Also hier noch rein. Ja, okay.
>> SALLY: Okay. Warte mal.
Vielleicht schiebst du deine Zutaten auch so hin.
>> FREDERIC: Du, ich schaffe das.
>> SALLY: Ja?
>> FREDERIC: Ich kriege das hin.
Ich bin gewohnt mit wenig Platz.
>> SALLY: Okay.
Und dann kann ich das schon mal hier erwärmen.
Also das Fleisch einfach in Würfel schneiden.
Es sollte auch nicht zu mager sein.
>> FREDERIC: Ich bin sofort da, ja?
>> SALLY: Es tut mir leid.
Ich habe es dir halt auch echt schwer gemacht
und bin auf die Seite mit mehr Platz.
>> FREDERIC: Ich finde das gut. Ich kriege das schon hin.
Für mich ist es
>> SALLY: schon schwer. >> FREDERIC: eine Challenge.
Weil im Prinzip symbolisiere ich gerade
die Leute, die mitkochen,
>> SALLY: Das stimmt!
>> FREDERIC: aber halt ohne das Video anzuhalten.
Wir kochen einfach parallel so.
>> FREDERIC: Ja.
>> SALLY: Auf 8 oder so.
>> FREDERIC: 8 oder so.
>> SALLY: Auf 8 passt.
Und dann das Fleisch am besten
in so 1-, 2-cm-Würfel.
>> FREDERIC: Hm, hm.
>> SALLY: Vielleicht kennt ja auch jemand von euch
dieses Rezept
und kann dann auch schreiben,
ob wir alles richtig machen.
Aber ich glaube schon.
>> FREDERIC: Hast du das schon mal gemacht? Nee, nicht?
>> SALLY: Nee.
>> FREDERIC: Hm.
>> SALLY: Du, ich habe da so ein Bild gesehen,
habe mich davon inspirieren lassen.
Ich habe auch ein bisschen was anders.
Weil ich muss halt
immer so meinen eigenen Touch reinbringen
und Rosmarin,
weil ich habe einfach so viel Rosmarin im Garten,
dass ich immer versuche,
den einfach zu verwerten.
>> FREDERIC: Ist deine Mutter eine gute Köchin?
>> SALLY: Meine Mutter ist eine echt gute Köchin.
>> FREDERIC: Hattest du sie schon mal hier?
>> SALLY: Sie war auch schon hier.
>> FREDERIC: Kochen im Video?
>> SALLY: Nee.
Wäre eigentlich auch mal. Ja.
Aber meine Mama, die ist so scheu
und so schüchtern und...
Aber ich müsste sie eigentlich mal
>> FREDERIC: Hm, überreden.
>> SALLY: überreden.
Und mit dem Papa vielleicht so Papas Lieblingsrezept, Josh.
>> FREDERIC: Oh, das ist bestimmt gut! Ja.
>> SALLY: Und vor allem ist der Papa megalustig.
>> FREDERIC: Hm.
>> SALLY: Okay.
Wenn ihr das dann habt,
dann könnt ihr
das Fleisch anbraten.
Am besten eigentlich das Fleisch vorher
auf Raumtemperatur kommen lassen.
[Musik]
Dann kann ich schon mal die Zwiebel und Knoblauchzehen
auch fein würfeln
auf meinem wunderschönen Schneidebrett.
>> FREDERIC: Zwiebel und Knoblauchzehen?
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> FREDERIC: Ich bin gleich wieder dran.
>> FREDERIC: Bei mir ist es warm auf jeden Fall.
>> SALLY: Ja.
Sieht gut aus.
>> FREDERIC: Ich kriege das schon hin.
>> SALLY: Das sieht gut aus.
[Musik]
>> FREDERIC: Darf ich?
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> FREDERIC: Rein? >> SALLY: Ja, ja.
>> SALLY: Rein und dann schön anbraten.
[Musik]
Also wir müssen sie schon scharf anbraten,
dass sie Röstaromen kriegen.
Ich hätte gleich, glaube ich, von Anfang an
ein bisschen höher stellen dürfen.
So wie du. Bei dir ist es super.
Mmh!
Siehst du? Die perfekte Farbe schon.
>> FREDERIC: Mit Absicht.
>> SALLY: Ich muss echt sagen,
bei dir sieht das Fleisch besser aus,
>> FREDERIC: Danke.
>> SALLY: weil einfach mehr Hitze drauf war.
Ich habe vorhin vergessen, wieder hochzustellen.
>> FREDERIC: Deines brennt gerade an.
>> SALLY: Sieht voll gut aus!
Also Fleisch dann rausnehmen,
wenn es schön angebraten ist.
Und dann die Hitze aber gerne ein bisschen reduzieren
und die Zwiebel und Knoblauchzehen
und Würfelchen anbraten.
Denn die brauchen jetzt nicht mehr so viel Hitze.
Rührst du?
>> FREDERIC: Ach so, ja, häufig.
Röstaromen.
>> SALLY: Oh!
>> FREDERIC: Röstaromen.
>> SALLY: Und da gebe ich jetzt den Deckel drauf,
damit es ein bisschen schmoren kann.
So. Jetzt kannst du hier alles reingeben.
>> FREDERIC: Yes, sir!
>> SALLY: Und dein Fleisch sieht echt perfekt aus!
>> FREDERIC: Und...
Musste da noch Öl rein oder so was jetzt?
>> SALLY: Nö, aber du kannst den Deckel drauf geben,
>> FREDERIC: Hm.
>> SALLY: dass es einfach so ein bisschen schmort.
>> FREDERIC: Okay.
Und Hitze ein bisschen runter, oder?
>> SALLY: Ja, so auf 6 ist okay.
>> FREDERIC: Okay.
>> SALLY: Die Karotten können wir ja
so in 5-mm-Scheiben schneiden.
>> FREDERIC: Hm.
>> SALLY: Die haben wir schon geschält.
Dann bleiben die so ein bisschen bissfester
und werden nicht so weich.
>> FREDERIC: Kriege ich hin.
>> SALLY: Vielleicht werden sie auch weich,
weil wir lassen es ja lange noch schmoren.
Aber dann ist auch okay.
Und dann
– huch!
Kurzer Schwächeanfall –
kann ich schon mal das Mehl darüber geben über die Zwiebeln,
mit anbraten,
damit die Soße gleich ein bisschen bindet.
>> FREDERIC: Hm.
>> SALLY: Klappt es?
>> FREDERIC: Ja, ja, ja. Alles sehr entspannt.
>> SALLY: Doch, das sieht gut aus!
Was ist dein Lieblingsrezept?
>> FREDERIC: Von dir?
>> SALLY: Ja.
Also jetzt ohne Bolognese.
>> FREDERIC: Eigentlich
– also das Eigentliche:
Spätzle mit Sauerbratensoße.
>> SALLY: Oh!
Oh, Spätzle!
>> FREDERIC: Mit ganz viel Sauerrahm.
Ist, glaube ich, von Oma. Ja.
>> SALLY: Ich habe noch nie Spätzle
auf meinem Kanal gemacht
>> FREDERIC: Echt?
>> SALLY: Und jetzt bist du da
und ich habe einfach keine Spätzle für dich gemacht.
>> FREDERIC: Ich habe sogar schon mal Spätzle gemacht.
>> SALLY: Hach!
>> FREDERIC: Ich kann das sehr gut!
>> SALLY: Ja, glaube ich dir, du Schwabe.
>> FREDERIC: So schwäbisch gut,
wo man dann einfach nur das
– badisch gut auch.
>> SALLY: Oh!
>> FREDERIC: Wo man dann einfach nur
die Teigmasse reinkloppt
und manchmal solche Teigbatzen dann hat
und sagt: "Ja, Spätzle!"
>> SALLY: Ich gucke es mir an.
Also guck mal. Mehl habe ich mit angebraten.
>> FREDERIC: Hm.
Müsste ich jetzt dann auch mal machen, nicht?
>> SALLY: Und dann mit der Brühe ablöschen.
Dann unsere W-Sauce.
>> FREDERIC: Okay.
Mehl mit anbraten.
>> SALLY: Ja.
Oh, die sind ja schwarz!
>> FREDERIC: Ja, das ist nicht schlimm.
Das sind Röstaromen.
>> SALLY: Nee, das sind Röstaromen.
>> FREDERIC: Dann Brühe.
Hm.
>> SALLY: Sieht sehr gut aus!
Die Hitze kann dann auch gleich wieder hoch.
>> FREDERIC: Hm.
>> SALLY: Und dann gebe ich noch die Gewürze dazu
und zwar die Lorbeerblätter,
etwas Pfeffer.
Den Thymian nicht bitte.
Der kommt nämlich auf die Kartoffeln.
Pfeffer.
Salz müssen wir gleich mal abschmecken
wegen der Gemüsebrühe.
>> FREDERIC: Also Gemüsebrühe.
Dann Lorbeerblätter?
>> SALLY: Gemüsebrühe, die Soße, die Worcester Sauce.
>> FREDERIC: Die Wor-
– die Worer.
>> SALLY: Worer.
>> FREDERIC: So.
>> SALLY: Lorbeer.
>> FREDERIC: Lorbeeren.
Beide?
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> FREDERIC: Und dann?
>> SALLY: Pfeffer.
>> FREDERIC: Pfeffer. Yes.
>> SALLY: Dann gebe ich die Karotten rein
und stelle die Hitze jetzt doch wieder runter,
dass es nicht so arg kocht,
und gebe das Fleisch wieder dazu.
>> FREDERIC: Hm.
>> SALLY: Damit es nur noch so ein bisschen siedet.
>> FREDERIC: Die Möhrchen hast du dann dazu getan, nicht?
>> SALLY: Die Möhrchen noch. Ja.
>> FREDERIC: Möhrchen rein, Fleisch rein?
>> SALLY: Hm.
Möhrchen rein, Fleisch rein.
Pfeffer hast du?
>> FREDERIC: Pfeffer habe ich schon reingemacht. Ja.
Und einen Schuss Salz.
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> FREDERIC: Für die Salzis hier.
>> SALLY: Ich gebe jetzt meinen Deckel drauf.
>> FREDERIC: Für die Bergziegen.
Also Deckel wieder drauf.
Und dann kann ich mich jetzt nämlich
um die Kartoffeln kümmern
>> FREDERIC: Hm.
>> SALLY: und die Kartoffeln einfach
– gewaschen sind sie –
in 5-mm-Scheiben hobeln.
Und das hoble ich jetzt, damit sie gleichmäßig dick werden,
>> FREDERIC: Okay.
>> SALLY: damit sie gleichmäßig gar werden gleich.
>> FREDERIC: Du hast so ein Hobelgerät, – nicht? –
dass man das da oben drauf machen kann.
>> SALLY: Fingerschutz. Ja, ja.
>> FREDERIC: Das, was da allen fehlt immer.
Und dann alle immer: "Ah! Aah! Aah!"
>> SALLY: Und dann der Finger.
>> FREDERIC: Ja, ja, das ist schlimm.
>> SALLY: Ja, ja.
Also bitte nie ohne Fingerschutz!
>> FREDERIC: Nee.
>> SALLY: Hast du dich schon mal geschnitten?
>> FREDERIC: Ich zeige jetzt mal nicht meine linke Hand.
Aber es ist auf jeden Fall...
Nach einer Zeit wächst es wieder nach.
>> SALLY: Oh, nein!
>> FREDERIC: Ja, danke.
>> SALLY: Also am Anfang mache ich immer so
und sobald dann die Kartoffel so leicht verschwindet,
>> FREDERIC: Aber da
– du hast ja auch schon so ein Inlay dafür.
Weißt du, ich würde das ja alles
>> SALLY: Ja, ja.
>> FREDERIC: mit der Hand machen.
Weil ich habe ja nicht mal so ein Inlay.
>> SALLY: Und dann rutschst du ab.
>> FREDERIC: Ich habe ja gar nicht so coole Gadgets.
>> SALLY: Und nach dem
– brauchst du etwa Gadgets?
Und nach dem Benutzen immer gleich auf null drehen, okay?
Damit sich keiner schneidet.
>> FREDERIC: Ach so.
>> SALLY: Aber ich gebe es jetzt dir rüber.
Deswegen drehe ich es auf.
Aber, wenn du fertig bist, dann auf null,
>> FREDERIC: Okay.
>> SALLY: dass wir uns beim Saubermachen nicht schneiden.
Das ist nämlich auch voll die Gefahrenquelle in der Küche.
Geht?
>> FREDERIC: Ja, ja.
Einfach das abziehen, oder?
>> SALLY: Ja, es klebt ein bisschen wegen der Kartoffelstärke.
>> FREDERIC: Ah! Ach so. Ja.
Wusste ich.
>> SALLY: So.
Dann
werde ich...
>> FREDERIC: Ich fühle mich
>> SALLY: Ich schmelze...
>> FREDERIC: so erwachsen!
>> SALLY: Ja!
>> FREDERIC: Sorry.
>> SALLY: Ich schmelze noch die Butter.
Und ich schmelze deine auch gleich mit.
>> FREDERIC: Danke schön. Sehr nett.
>> SALLY: Bitte.
Ja, so bin ich halt.
Ich bin voll nett zu dir.
>> FREDERIC: Also die sind von mir approved,
das Gerät hier.
>> SALLY: Ja?
>> FREDERIC: Das finde ich gut.
>> SALLY: Ist gut?
>> FREDERIC: Ja.
>> SALLY: Da gibt es sogar
noch so einen Einsatz.
Ja, du kannst einfach drüber so
mit der nächsten.
>> FREDERIC: Hm.
Und dann gibt es da noch so einen Einsatz
und dann kannst du auch Julienne schneiden.
Weißt du? So Stifte.
>> FREDERIC: Wen?
>> SALLY: Julienne.
>> FREDERIC: Bam?
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> FREDERIC: Julien Bam?
>> SALLY: Julienne Bam.
>> FREDERIC: Julien Bam, ich scheide dich.
Direkt aus Frankreich.
Ich mache dich einen Kopf kleiner, du Breakdancer.
>> SALLY: Julienne kannst du schneiden.
>> FREDERIC: Julienne. Ah, oui, oui.
>> SALLY: Oui.
So. Die Kartoffeln gebe ich dann hier rein.
Ich finde die auch echt schön mit Schale.
>> FREDERIC: Ist gut, nicht?
>> SALLY: Mit so...
Ja.
>> FREDERIC: Oh!
>> SALLY: Das gibt so
einfach so eine schöne Optik.
>> FREDERIC: Natur.
>> SALLY: Ja.
Und die jetzt mit Salz und Pfeffer vermischen.
Da kommt noch Thymian drauf.
>> FREDERIC: Hey, hallo, was ist das denn?
Ah!
Aua, aua!
[Musik]
>> SALLY: Wir sind wieder einsatzbereit.
Sorry für den...
>> FREDERIC: Fünf bis zehn Minuten.
>> SALLY: Sorry für den Zwischenfall.
Ich bin nicht ohnmächtig geworden.
Sturmi auch nicht,
weil der sich hingesetzt hat.
>> FREDERIC: Teilweise.
Wir saßen beide voreinander.
>> SALLY: Ich habe die Bilder wieder aus dem Kopf verdrängt.
>> FREDERIC: Jetzt reicht es.
>> SALLY: Okay.
Aber unser
Menu sieht wundervoll aus.
>> FREDERIC: Ich muss, glaube ich, noch
die Kartoffeln nachholen, nicht?
>> SALLY: Oh, ja, stimmt.
Die Kartoffeln mit Thymian, Salz und Pfeffer vermischen.
>> FREDERIC: Hm.
>> SALLY: Und dann kommt so ein richtig schöner Part.
Oh! Und Rosmarin natürlich wollten wir ja auch dazu nehmen.
So etwas Rosmarin!
Den zupfen wir so mit rein.
Oh, das riecht doch gleich perfekt gut!
Und jetzt kann ich schon mal den Herd ausmachen.
Und das habe ich jetzt gesehen.
Das sieht echt megacool aus!
Da musst du jetzt bitte aufpassen,
dass du dich nicht verbrennst!
Nimm nicht...
>> FREDERIC: Ich doch nie! Was?
>> SALLY: Und dann die Kartoffeln so fächerförmig
>> FREDERIC: Ach du heilige Mutter Gottes!
>> SALLY: einfach hier drauf.
Und das sieht dann am Ende
schon ziemlich, ziemlich gut aus.
>> FREDERIC: Okay.
>> SALLY: Guck mal, die kleinen,
die schmeiße ich so unten rein.
Das,
die Arbeit mache ich mir nicht.
>> FREDERIC: Da kommt ja richtig viel raus.
Das ist ja so eine Genugtuung.
Rosmarin?
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> FREDERIC: Da reinzupfen?
>> SALLY: Yes.
Einfach so nach Gefühl, so viel, wie du möchtest.
>> FREDERIC: Ja. Und jetzt ordentlich,
jetzt aber erst mal ganz schön.
>> SALLY: Ich hoffe, ich habe die richtige Menge an Kartoffeln.
Wenn nicht, klaue ich sie dir.
Wow, wow, wow!
Das sieht wundervoll aus!
Das ist so ein Rezept, finde ich,
wenn du das mit zur Mama bringst,
da ist die Mama begeistert.
>> FREDERIC: Bist du sicher?
>> SALLY: Ja. Oder?
>> FREDERIC: Mh.
>> SALLY: Da sieht sie:
"Mensch, da hat sie sich Mühe gegeben
und die Kartoffeln, jede einzelne
hier angereiht."
Da-d-d-da-daa.
Bitte ver-
>> FREDERIC: Riecht aber lecki.
>> SALLY: Bitte verbrenne dich nicht.
>> FREDERIC: Was ist denn los jetzt?!
Einmal einen Fehler gemacht.
Das ist jetzt eine kleine Fleischwunde.
>> SALLY: Okay.
Kurz zusammengenäht.
>> FREDERIC: Ach, so...
Vielleicht.
Finden wir raus.
Nein, Quatsch.
Und das dann jetzt nur da drüber.
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> FREDERIC: Von außen nach innen?
>> FREDERIC: Hast du runtergedreht?
Ja, du hast es ausgemacht.
>> SALLY: Ja, ja. Ich habe es ausgemacht,
damit es nicht blubbert
und wir uns nicht verbrennen.
>> FREDERIC: Ich schaffe das schon.
>> SALLY: Ich lege jetzt so die kleinen
Anfangs- und Endstücke hier unten doch noch rein,
dass die verschwunden sind
und ich sie eben einfach mitverarbeite.
Und
optisch halt auch,
dass ich die kleinen jetzt nicht obendrauf liegen haben.
Was hattest du in der Schule
– tatsächlich, das wollte ich dich echt mal fragen –
>> FREDERIC: Hm.
>> SALLY: so als Kurse?
>> FREDERIC: Oberstufe oder generell?
>> SALLY: Ja, Oberstufe.
>> FREDERIC: Ich hatte Leistungskurse Deutsch und Englisch
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> FREDERIC: und Grundkurse hatte ich...
>> SALLY: Darf ich das noch bei dir reinschmeißen
einfach so?
>> FREDERIC: Mir reicht es jetzt.
Du hast einfach da so das Ende von einer Kartoffel
>> SALLY: Leer.
>> FREDERIC: reingetan. Das stört mich jetzt.
>> FREDERIC: Ich hatte Deutsch-, Englisch-Leistungskurse
und Geschichte-
und Mathe-Grundkurse.
Also klassisches Kartoffelabi, sage ich immer.
>> SALLY: Boah, Geschichte!
Ich habe Geschichte gehasst!
>> FREDERIC: Na, wir hatten halt
den besten Lehrer der Schule.
Der war der Geschichtslehrer.
Deswegen wollten das alle machen.
Und der war halt richtig cool.
>> SALLY: Unser Geschichtslehrer war auch megacool.
Das war echt so auch einer meiner Lieblingslehrer.
Aber ich konnte mich mit der Geschichte nicht anfreunden.
Ich dachte, ich lerne da halt was,
und dann hatte ich meine einzige 5-6 in der Schullaufbahn.
>> FREDERIC: Echt?
>> SALLY: Hm.
Ich hasse
– ich kann Geschichte nicht.
Das sieht voll schön aus!
Ja.
Aber deine Kartoffeln, du hast noch Kartoffeln übrig.
>> FREDERIC: Ich habe übel viel Kartoffeln.
Wie kriege ich die denn jetzt da vernünftig reingelegt?
Ich war hier schon außen irgendwie so ein bisschen unterwegs.
>> SALLY: Guck hier. Weißt du? So.
Dann hättest du hier noch mehr über.
Weißt du? So überfächern.
>> FREDERIC: Verbrenn dich nicht.
Tu dir nicht weh an dem Ding jetzt!
>> SALLY: Ich kann meine
>> FREDERIC: Es reicht schon einer.
>> SALLY: Hände in eine Fritteuse stecken.
>> FREDERIC: Hast du Omahände?
>> SALLY: Ja, ich habe Omahände.
>> FREDERIC: Oh, Gold!
Ich hatte megaviele Kartoffeln!
>> SALLY: Wir hatten gleich viele!
>> FREDERIC: Das stimmt überhaupt nicht!
>> SALLY: Doch!
>> FREDERIC: Du hast mir viel mehr gegeben,
um mich zu verunsichern.
Und jetzt bin ich unsicher.
>> SALLY: Gar nicht.
Gar nicht.
>> FREDERIC: Da ist auch noch ein Stück Finger mit drin.
Nein, Quatsch, ist es gar nicht.
Entschuldigung.
>> SALLY: Sollen wir die in eine Auflaufform machen und so?
>> FREDERIC: Können wir machen.
>> SALLY: Okay.
Guck mal. Ich habe bei mir noch ein bisschen Rosmarin drauf,
einfach
>> FREDERIC: Für die Optik.
>> SALLY: wegen der Optik, wegen des Geschmacks.
Und dann wird die Kartoffelschicht mit Butter bestrichen,
mit flüssiger.
Für den Geschmack.
Und dann darf das auch schon in den Backofen
wirklich bei schön niedriger Temperatur.
Dann wird das Fleisch schön zart,
die Kartoffeln werden weich.
Und wir können in der Zwischenzeit was backen.
>> FREDERIC: Das finde ich gut.
>> SALLY: Finde ich auch gut.
Und dann haben wir später ein richtig leckeres
Mittagessen, Abendessen,
>> FREDERIC: Ein Essen.
>> SALLY: was auch immer an Essen, Hauptgericht.
Und auf jeden Fall mit Deckel kochen.
Deswegen habe ich auch hier
den Gusseisentopf gewählt.
Ansonsten, wenn ihr einen Gusseisentopf nicht habt,
könnt ihr auch eine Auflaufform nehmen
und vorher natürlich das Gericht im Topf kochen,
dann umfüllen.
Aber ihr solltet es auf jeden Fall abdecken,
damit einfach das Ganze geschmort wird,
nicht trocken wird und wirklich schön durchziehen kann.
Ich finde, wir haben gut gekocht.
>> FREDERIC: Ja, ich auch.
Also ich freue mich tatsächlich drauf, wenn es fertig ist,
muss ich sagen.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> FREDERIC: Wie lang muss es in den Ofen?
>> SALLY: Ach, ich würde schon sagen,
schon eine Stunde.
>> FREDERIC: Schon ein Stündchen? Okay.
>> SALLY: Hm. Schön langsam.
Ja. Hast du es leer gemacht?
>> FREDERIC: Hm.
>> SALLY: Perfekt!
Dann ab in den Ofen!
[Musik]
Komm, mach du.
Und jetzt so wusch.
>> FREDERIC: Und patz,
einfach so durch das Gesicht gelatscht.
>> SALLY: Okay.
>> FREDERIC: Hm.
>> SALLY: Wow!
Wow!
>> FREDERIC: Ähnlich!
>> SALLY: Das sieht gut aus!
>> FREDERIC: Ja?
>> SALLY: Doch!
>> FREDERIC: Oder?
Ist ein Leckobert.
>> SALLY: Das ist echt Leckobert.
>> FREDERIC: Nicht? Langsam kommt der Leckobert hier rein.
>> SALLY: Hm, langsam, langsam.
>> FREDERIC: Und das gemeinsame Kochbuch
"Die Leckoberts".
Durchrühren oder anschneiden?
>> SALLY: Oh nee, ich würde es, glaube ich,
einfach so schön rausschöpfen.
>> FREDERIC: Okay.
>> SALLY: Boah!
Das sieht schon gut aus.
>> FREDERIC: Puh! Das riecht so lecker!
>> SALLY: Mmh!
>> FREDERIC: Das riecht so lecker!
>> FREDERIC: Boah!
Ich hatte ja immer
– ich habe, glaube ich, tatsächlich
mit dir jetzt das erste Mal Lamm zubereitet.
>> SALLY: Echt?
>> FREDERIC: Habe ich noch nie gemacht. Nee.
>> SALLY: Ich liebe Lamm!
>> FREDERIC: My firsts.
Aber du hast total wenig reingetan.
Ich würde so acht Löffel
>> SALLY: Nee.
>> FREDERIC: da drauf schaufeln, weil so:
"Oh, das riecht so gut!"
>> SALLY: Mit dem Hintergrund, ich muss noch Bilder machen.
>> FREDERIC: Ja, schon gut.
>> SALLY: Darf ich bei dir probieren.
>> FREDERIC: Hm.
>> SALLY: Ich meine, eigentlich muss es ja gleich schmecken.
>> FREDERIC: Ja, hoffe ich.
Also sonst...
Mh.
>> SALLY: Jetzt nicht verbrennen.
Ich hoffe, es ist zart.
Mmh!
>> FREDERIC: Noch so warm?
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> FREDERIC: Ich puste jetzt erst mal zehn Minuten. Also
ich kann auch kurz aus dem Bild.
>> SALLY: Nur noch 140°C.
Wow!
Das ist voll zart!
Willst du auch probieren, Samira?
>> SAMIRA: Ja.
>> SALLY: Ja?
>> SAMIRA: Warte. Ich nehme mir einen Löffel.
>> SALLY: Ich finde, mit einem Löffel ist es schon gut.
Weil unten die Soße ist schon noch so suppig.
>> FREDERIC: Das mag ich.
>> SALLY: Ich auch. Also ich finde, es muss nicht immer...
>> FREDERIC: Sehr schwäbisch.
>> SALLY: Ja. Es muss nicht immer so gebunden sein alles.
Und dann kann man schön noch Brot reintunken.
Hm.
Bei mir fehlt ein Ticken Salz.
Aber ansonsten...
>> FREDERIC: Ich habe es gesalzen.
>> SALLY: Ja.
Ah! Siehst du, ich habe es nicht gesalzen.
>> SAMIRA: Mmh!
>> SALLY: Voll gut!
>> FREDERIC: Hm.
>> SALLY: Also ich bin echt ein Fan.
>> FREDERIC: Megalecker!
Das ist wirklich sehr lecker!
>> SALLY: Ich finde es super.
>> SALLY: Supersuperlecker! >> SAMIRA: Voll lecker!
>> FREDERIC: Was?
>> JOSH: Blut verloren dafür.
>> FREDERIC: Was bitte?
>> SALLY: Er hat viel Blut verloren.
>> FREDERIC: Ich habe viel Blut verloren.
Ich kann nicht mehr reden.
>> SALLY: Eigentlich hat er hier hinten dran
>> FREDERIC: Ich habe gar kein Blut verloren,
>> SALLY: so ein Stativ.
>> FREDERIC: ehrlich gesagt. Das war nicht so viel.
>> SALLY: Doch, war es schon,
>> FREDERIC: Nein.
>> SALLY: war schon tief geschnitten.
>> SAMIRA: Voll lecker!
>> FREDERIC: Ja.
>> SALLY: Ich finde es auch megalecker!
Ja. Und ich fand das auch cool,
hier so Partner-Cooking zu machen.
>> FREDERIC: Fand ich auch. Ja.
>> SALLY: So richtig so parallel.
Echt schön!
Ja.
>> FREDERIC: Solltest du öfters machen.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> FREDERIC: Hm.
>> SALLY: Also probiert das Rezept gern mal aus.
Ich hoffe, Murat kocht auch mal mit mir.
Der kocht nie mit mir!
>> FREDERIC: Ich überrede den schon noch.
>> SALLY: Aber ich bin doch ein angenehmer Kochpartner,
oder?
>> FREDERIC: Ja.
Auch sehr guter Lehrer.
>> SALLY: Oh!
>> FREDERIC: Ich würde es nachkochen.
>> SALLY: Ja, ich auch noch mal.
Hm.
>> SAMIRA: Ich auch.
>> SALLY: Ihr findet das Rezept in meiner App
oder auf dem Blog, auf sallys-blog.de
oder in der "Sallys Welt"-App.
Probiert es gerne mal aus.
Danke, Sturmi, dass du da bist die komplette Woche.
Wir haben echt sehr viel Spaß zusammen.
Eine schöne Zeit!
[Musik]